I was born in Brussels Belgium January
834 and I had a very happy childhood
until the Nazi came in the star the star
everyone was wearing a star what did
your non-jewish friend everybody was
looking at us of course and when I
wanted to have a good time and play with
the other kids I would take off the
staff and my mother would yell and
scream and she's you cannot do this you
cannot do this you have George little
girl and you must wear the star that's
what they want that's what they want
I remember just she telling me that and
I said but the kids don't want to play
with me if I wear this and until that
note came from the school and that we
could not go to school that's when
really the whole thing started and my
mother hide away where we lived the
landlady ed nephew was a priest in a
real town outside persons and she
contact the landlady and she said you
know they taking away the Trenton all
hatred the Jewish friends are going can
you do something about my daughter
can you take a hide off somewhere and
the lady says yes I did his nephew was a
priest yeah we'll ask him and that's
what's the arrangement
I remember my father crying like a baby
in the middle of the street while he was
taking me to the to those people and to
strangers and he explained to me
don't forget your Jewish little girl
we're gonna see you again but you must
do that you must go away and we're doing
this for you best because of course I
couldn't understand my mother was crying
and only my father could take me and
explain to me you got to go this is for
you good this is for you good
it's the best for you so I went out of
town going with those people and this
was just before my birthday and the last
time I saw my father was on my birthday
he took a chance
and went to the priests house to see me
and yet suitable suit for me as I told
you it was a tailor and it came in and I
I was hiding behind the door I want to
surprise him and the quiz say oh yes I
changed my name I chant my name was no
more hatred of course was was out of
flow that was my first name I had about
three other names it was all on the
floor and the priest
Theodore Kunj I see my height in front
of me I love him
he says who's that who's that come home
I have a surprise for you and I said oh
really and I was scared I thought maybe
something would happen and I hide behind
the door I didn't know it was my father
then I heard this voice and everyone and
the last time I saw my father he had
this suit for me and yet I will watch on
the suit it was clean I will never
forget it and my mother cannot come
because they were arresting people all
over and if they came as a couple they
would never hurt them together but the
way her has stood the week after and
they were sent to my name and all the
way arrested I have to tell you the
story as I told you the landlady who who
got the priest to save me could not take
the pressure and she went to the Gestapo
yes this is a fact and she went to the
Gestapo and she said you must come to my
house I'm hiding Jews come and get it
people went that far to denounce other
people to her a lot of people to build
actually build things to destroy human
human face and by the way not only
Jewish people suffer I mean I can tell
you nuns were shot
the mother of my priest are calling my
priest she was Ivan my clothing one day
and the Gestapo came in and she said and
they said we know you hiding a Jewish
child and she's absolutely not I am NOT
you can look all over I'm not hiding
under foucha they put her in front of
the house and six Nazi well I saw
through my eye around eyes because I was
done in the cellar and she said no you
can shoot me I don't have a Jewish child
here and this was the mother of the
priest so there were people that we're
so Coolidge's so marvelous and yet the
contrary is so absolutely disgusting
that it's too much of a difference of
human being I understand how you can
call the whole thing you mean raise its
monsters and then there's the human pins
let's see
it's weird I feel very weird sometimes I
feel weird because I said to myself why
did I come out of it I mean if my mother
had said let's hide together I wouldn't
be here it is it so strange is just
absolutely very strange it was
Valentine's Day and in the Catholic
religion I mean I was in the convent by
now in the Catholic religion it's a big
holiday of course and all the children
are supposed to walk and have a good
time together and you choose a maid for
the day kind of and you had this big
basket and everybody grabs a name from
the basket
and that's who you were supposed to go
to all day with you know to play with
and to go with and in the middle of this
epi affair the priest came in the home
and he called me over and says who's the
house I don't tell anyone but I must
take you away don't tell anyone that
where you going
who you going with don't say well just
come with me and I said I wanna have a
good time what'd you talk I wanna go
with you and I'm having a good time no
you must come
scum and of course I went he took me to
moss
that was another a ton and we walked we
worked day and night we would stop in
thumbs at night and sleep in on the
floor whatever and there will be always
someone to give us food and and that's
where he told me that my parents had
been taken that will not do for my
parents for a while and I just had to do
what he said to me to do it will take me
to another convent to another where
there would be other children and all
not to tell anyone so we got two months
walking I don't know how we got there
but we were walking walking walking
constantly in I really don't know how it
is it was a few days a few nights and we
got there the first thing they're not
the non did they change my name again
there was Genevieve LeBlanc and I said
why to change names and this was but
that's what it was gonna be a blip on
that's where first I went to church I
went to Mass I went to communion I went
to confession they told me to be a
little girl in the convent to I mean
forget what was the past
that's what you love now and you are
hidden you are hiding and you must be
like the other children and I was I went
to Mass and I'm and I loved it by the
way because it was a life with other
people I wasn't running anymore
I was settled a little bit and now
Jillian I like that I must say I was
very happy there
I remember things very tender moments
with nuns came at night - doc doc -
cover me and and such an of years no
panel oh and I remember they would teach
me in the dark are to go to Mass because
I didn't know what to do and they would
say you must come because of you that
you will find out that you don't know
how to do this and you must not to do
this because you know you hear now and I
love them all I mean I have moments
beautiful moments then I went to another
convent and many other places always
walking during the night following
people who would take us to those places
until we hit Luverne Luverne is a
seminar it's a very big convent and it's
a seminar they teach the priests to
become priests and the six nuns who cook
for them and I have this little house on
the side who cook for them and make the
laundry and all that and that's where I
was with those nuns and one day the
Gestapo came in and the Carmelite they
were Carmelite nuns and as you know the
men cannot go there it's one of their
whole they cannot see men and then knock
on the door and we wonder with the guns
and all that we won that Jewish trial we
know you have a Jew child there and
announcing absolutely not absolutely
don't have anybody here and they bought
the door
and while I will never forget is that
the six nuns their big basket of laundry
that they carry three on the side
because there was a lot of laundry for
all this please and they push me in that
laundry to hide me and they put all the
linen on top that happened like in one
second and that's how I was safe in that
basket and they work a deeply a game
like they work at the laundry and the
Gestapo was looking all over and I was
in that basket with the laundry on top
of me
and that's one way I escaped that time
but then for some reason it started all
over and I had to keep on going from one
place to another
now why they wanted the seven years old
child I will never understand never and
all of children of course also and many
children as a matter of fact when they
come back on the weekends their parents
wanted to take them on weekends they
never came back
you never saw them probably the way I
rested where they do did you yeah oh you
know how do you know when there was
something that we knew for some reason
we didn't want to tell openly but we
knew we had a feel kind of it's
difficult to explain we yeah that like
we didn't know exactly what to do in
sure we were not like the other children
with we didn't know when to go on those
knees and things like that so we knew
like this little girl you know said she
wanted a piece of chocolate she didn't
have chocolate for a long time and I
said she meet me - how come we don't get
chocolate and we don't get visitors on
weekends and that's how we find out
nobody came to see us on a Sunday all
the other children their parents came to
see and we had nobody another place took
me to this other house and then I wind
up in the earth then all the way and
always walking I mean that song what I
remember walking at night with different
people don't ask me their names because
I do not know and I wind up in
which is in the earth then there I was
sent to this marvelous family they never
had children before never the minute I
walk in there I feel like I was one of
them the fear I have for those people is
absolutely incredible when I came to
their house I was so used to going to
Mass in the morning to 6 o'clock in the
morning mass that I would beg them to
wake me up and go to and send me to Mass
six o'clock in the morning because I was
used to it in the continent and I loved
it and I would cry if they did not wake
me 6 o clock in the morning did they
know you were George yes this man was
with the resistance
the Belgium has its downs in his youth
he was a colonial in the Congo he had
seen a lot of denrin is youth and when
the Nazi came into Belgium he was one of
the resistance
he used to blow up bridges and you know
whatever he could do and when you know
that was neat to other child it took me
in they also changed my name again and
if someone was man whose deep own why I
mean this the old thing is so absolutely
incredible and as I go although his
getting worse
it's absolutely getting worse and to
this day he writes to me now he hosts
the poem sometimes and I begged him call
me her she called me Rachel you know
this is a long time call me later
and I still get letter now he holds my
share petite nahi hos like I was a child
of his and one day after nine months
the war was over nine months I'm sitting
there in the classroom and it's non
waxing and with all well she just looked
at me and I just knew my mother was I
for two weeks before I had made such a
life I could not sleep I was screaming
my mother my mother and for three years
I never even thought of them to me my
parents had left me and I was very mad
at my balance because I didn't
understand to me I was only a child and
they had left me to all this cancer and
it was hurting me very much and nor what
I remember didn't want to see my mother
because to me she had left me little did
I know if if I had gone with her who had
been boys in the oven because that's
what they would do they would put the
mother and the child hide in the oven
but those this or what I knew as a child
she had left me and when I saw her I
didn't want to go to her she was right
there in in the principal office from
the convent and it meant ciated I mean I
knew no it was my mother only they told
me it was my brother and I took me a
long time to understand that she saved
my life but if she didn't hide me I
would be here to tell you the story I
just want so I took me a long long time
to get to Danko for it done that a long
time and my mother was in Auschwitz
three years my bad my father didn't come
back and you asked me how did I know
about mrs. Mann he knows but that
landlady after she my mother took me
from the convent
they had a few friends who took that
home the hot closet giving them because
they have nothing and the Red Cross was
taking care of them giving them clothing
and all that and
we slept on the floor I must say 3/4
woman and I all friends of my mother on
sofa maschwitz and
one day my mother says you know we have
to go back to see mrs. marinas we went
back behind the band the lady opened the
door she looked at us like we were
ghosts she fell on the floor she kissed
my mother's feet she didn't know what to
say she says I did that to you I did
that to you I am the one who denounced
you will God ever forgive me I will
never forget that same never never and
then when my mother said I know it's you
who gave her sin because one of the
Gestapo said we know you are Jews
because the landlady told us so then
when she fell on O which when she saw us
she could not could not believe we were
alive she couldn't believe it and she
hugged me that she did that my mother
was only thirty years old and she was a
beautiful woman
she still is and now this kind of a our
person can see so much and be still you
know happy sometimes she has sad eyes
she's not in a good health of course but
how can a person like that go back to
life I have to sing such earth has
always been very intriguing to me after
the war
as I told you the head cause of all
these people is and all this
organization came about and my mother
met of second husband who always also
came out from Auschwitz and lost his
wife in other fits on the line to get
food in the head cause place where they
would get food and that's why she met
our second husband and they mahi and a
fuse a few years later there the Sun
which writing is absolutely incredible
because the two of them with a number
and coming from hell and then this
beautiful ball is after that I think I
believe in God when I think about my
brother I really think that it's really
you know they both came out from hell
and they have this continuation there
it's beautiful boy it's amazing
you were brought up really for a good
part of your young life as a Catholic
how do you feel now about being joy it's
a really difficult question I told her
that many many times I identify him more
as a human being I would say I think I'm
a good person and I help people and
that's what I wanted to I don't care if
I'm Catholic Jewish or whatever I want
to finish my life as a good person
and then of people it's the way I can
show to be children oh yes I work a lot
with children I have children and
preview the function world they raised
you
yes they yeah but they know all about
the past they know about the beautiful
people who saved my life and one problem
with that they are confusions and that's
the truth and I can see why then you can
see why